hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember so you don't have to Kremlin's
jaws Beetlejuice water sit down
Raiders of the Lost Ark frozen inside
out Kung Fu Panda the lego movie mr.
Magoo what do all these movies have in
common they're all strangely enough
rated PG at least that's what the O is
logical Motion Picture Association of
America says for those who somehow don't
know America has five ratings for films
G for general audiences of all ages PG
for parental guidance suggested pg-13
for some material might be inappropriate
for children under 13 are for restricted
anyone under 17 needs an adult and n
c---seventeen for you must be seventy to
watch it doesn't sound like a bad system
except when you ask the question how is
this in the same league as this this or
the bigger question why is this movie
that obviously doesn't need parental
guidance suggesting it when it seems
identical to another movie that doesn't
suggest it they're even made by the same
company well to best understand it's
probably best to look at the history of
the rating system EC years ago there was
really just only three ratings g PG and
R and everything else was just born but
if you had one of these ratings you're
not born and you could be shown in the
majority of theaters mostly made sense
one was acceptable for most people one
might be a little iffy for some and one
was clearly just for adults because of
this the ratings were a little bit more
relaxed than you may think of them today
films like plan of the apes the haunting
and true grit are all movies that no one
in the right mind would call G nowadays
with several swear words
off screen violence on screen violence
tons of deaths it's a pretty dark
intense situations but the idea back
then was people knew there be some risk
going in as in you can't shield
everything from everyone that didn't
always make the ratings right hell all
three of these films can have some very
disturbing scenes in them but they
seemed ethically sound and not
kill everybody of every age want
entertainment after all and they knew
there had to be some intense moments to
keep you engaged that's just kind of the
gamble you take when you see a film even
if it is rated G but as movies went on
the envelope was pushed more and more
and some movies weren't really extreme
enough for an R but PG didn't seem to
cover it even when Indiana Jones and the
Temple of Doom came out they didn't know
where to place it it was certainly more
than a PG but not too much more than
Raiders of the Lost Ark which was also
pushing the PG rating thus the pg-13 was
born a compromise that seemed to fit in
between the two the upside is the
loopholes for this rating allowed in
many respects much more violence for our
blood hungry thirteen-year-old Minds to
take in resulting in funny enough even
more violence than a lot of r-rated
films the downside is for years this is
all people wanted to make you see
because of this rating there was
suddenly more of a distinction between G
and PG G was now seen as not really
general audiences anymore but kids and
eventually when you saw that rating you
would think oh a kid's only movie PG
suddenly could buckle down a little bit
more and let things that could fly and
say Planet of the Apes the haunting and
so forth suddenly not fly now because of
this the G rating was now being
stigmatized as baby movies which hey
we're growing adults and 10 to 16 year
olds who want to be grown adults we
don't want to watch that crap G will be
suck now a lot of kids hated them so
much we start marketing r-rated movies
as toys terminators back to fight evil
with his mobile assault vehicle talking
an electronic robot
in three action-packed sizes it was a
little missed up cool but a little
messed up this met obviously not as made
people want to see them because of this
what we're obviously g-rated movies
start throwing in one or two elements
that are completely pointless but help
get that PG rating they do this to show
hey there's something in this movie
you're not supposed to see and that
makes it a little risque right remember
the out of nowhere swear words and
Casper Ryan giant the bitch how about
the mountain of awkward adult jokes and
dr. Seuss movies dirty ho yeah thank God
your parents are there to help you
understand those totally childish
moments parading as adult moments
clearly this was made for people with a
more mature mind what they missed though
is that a lot of the great films are
g-rated and actually got away with a lot
more by being clever and dare I say it
necessary Disney was the reigning
champion of that for years for decades
and decades they produce nothing but
g-rated material by turning their
limitations into their advantage they
gave us some of the most messed up stuff
a lot of it was dark nightmarish and
intense but not always in the way that
would get a PG rating because they had
to find new avenues that people wouldn't
think of if they had the luxury of a PG
movie films like Bambi or Lion King
having ten scenes of family members
getting killed hell sometimes you even
see the body but because they worked in
that this is a part of life that's
important and worth understanding it can
still count as a G film perception is
everything that all changed in 1979
though when Disney released its first PG
film the black hole it sucked so they
opened a new studio where they could get
away with more PG material called
touchstone it seemed to work for a while
but PG eventually did work its way into
dominating Disney films once again and
even finally move down to pg-13 with
Pirates of the Caribbean and well I
liked that film fine it does raise the
question how far away are they getting
from Disney's original plan
entertainment that anyone could and
should be allowed to see is there an
r-rated film in the future more
importantly is it even needed i remember
much more great and disturbing imagery
from Hunchback of Notre Dame or
snow-white than anything in Lone Ranger
or the other pirate films so what's even
the point of trying to get the higher
rating that was however a point when G
films were becoming popular again and
that was with the invention of Pixar
studios they start off making Toy Story
a smash hit g-rated film for a long time
every Pixar film was G and every movie
was trying to be just like them the
adult talking childlike characters with
celebrity voices that talked about
children's scenarios and make them
intelligent and adult all without having
to resort to the gimmick of the PG
rating then the little hit came along
called Shrek and it showed that a PG
animated kids film can be little
naughtier than Pixar suddenly Shrek was
the movie everyone wanted to try and be
like even though Pixar was doing fine
with the g-rated storylines but then
something terrible started to happen to
Pixar
they started to suck nuts a card but
hard enough and as a lot of suits in
Hollywood usually think it must be
because they're not hip enough yeah
let's throw up he in front of that G for
I don't know an innuendo
some scary imagery what's that line in
frozen okay we get what size what size
doesn't matter yeah throw it in there to
get the PG rating that shows that we're
edgy thus the G movie practically feels
extinct again even though most parents
don't even bother watching a Pixar or
Disney film with their kid at least not
for parental guidance it feels like they
just put it on there so if you want to
complain about something stupid they
could just point and say well there's
the PG warning resulting in unneeded
adult scenes that only lasts a second to
prove that a movie is somehow naughty or
edgy when really it's nothing of the
sort
sometimes it can even work in the other
direction Tim Burton's Alice in
Wonderland has I stabbed and plucked out
heads floating in water with people
climbing on them and even a pretty
graphic decapitation see it only got a
PG rating when
is borderline our Dark Knight mod hit
that ever marketable pg-13 rating so
they cut corners by showing nobody
drinking very few swear words and little
to no sex which balanced out all the
shit ton of super intense violence and
even gory imagery in fact movies like
Hunger Games and other pg-13 films
actually have more violence in than the
most r-rated movies now but as long as
they don't show too much blood or say a
curse word it's okay to see children
slaughtered this is no surprise though
is the rating system for some time has
been incredibly inconsistent and what's
the word looking for insane
for example the f-word could be used
once in PG movies for years you'll
notice them snuck into films like
Spaceballs and Beetlejuice I got a PG
rating now this change recently the
pg-13 and it has to be used when not
talking about sex
so when Wolverine drops the f-bomb in
two x-men movies putting complete and
total attention on it but if he said it
one more time or used it talking about
sex the only the 17-year old mind can
understand that South Park made a great
mockery of a similar rule declaring that
if over four hundred swear words are
used in your film
it'll get an nc-17 rating which most
theaters won't play how many did they
use 399 insert slow clap here thank God
they didn't use that one more swear or
else that would have been too much oh by
the way it's totally okay that you show
a gigantic clitoris and make that part
of the story but if they said one more
swear word that would have been too far
actually a lot of things involving sex
in the rating system don't make any
sense now don't get me wrong I think sex
should be taught at the right time and
very delicately but by age 13 I think
most kids have an understanding of what
it is as well as the responsibilities
that come with it yeah I've seen they
practice those responsibilities but they
know what they are get the number of
times you show people humping can make
the difference between an R and an nc-17
things like three humps will get in an R
before we get an nc-17
nudity is something that has to be
blocked out a lot even though you can
save yep word once and show children
getting slaughtered and faces getting
burned up but God help you if there's a
nipple in there something everybody has
on top of that the way the ratings are
done are bizarre too if you check out
the movie appropriately title the still
does not yet rated they go into the
details about how you can see the people
who are rating it nor know their
identity nor reference past films that
got a different rating even if your film
does the exact same thing all of that is
bonkers bottom line the rating system
has been and continues to be incredibly
outdated and even kind of meaningless in
this age of the internet where any
information can be found at any time
children teens and adults are learning
more and faster than they ever have in
the past the rating system needs to
reflect that now don't get me wrong I
know it's all subjective one kid can
watch the G rated Snow White and be fine
another can watch it and get nightmares
it's never going to be a perfect system
nor should it be it's art it should be
subjective but the ratings should
reflect our current environment and be
more consistent
why is drag me to hell in over-the-top
gorefest pg-13 but love is strange we're
a gay couple kiss rated R yeah
there's nothing else in this movie
except a gay couple kissing and sleeping
in bed
totally clothed that was D more
inappropriate than this it makes no
sense in our current environment I guess
it's easy to say things have either
gotten too inconsiderate or things have
gotten too PC but the fact is they're
both right none of it makes any sense
from any angle it's a different world
now and the rating system is changing
but not in a way that reflects it I know
these aren't law and a lot of younger
people can still sneak into our rated
films and such and I also know there
always be loopholes and
everything but if the idea is to help
guide people to what will culturally be
accepted to the mass public this current
system doesn't really do that this
should be gee this should be our and
both should be glad that they're Aegean
and are the secret to cinematic success
isn't the rating it's making a good film
Toy Story was a hit despite of being a
g-rated kids Ville Deadpool was a hit
despite it being an r-rated superhero
flick how did they do that what was the
secret they were good changes need to
happen on both sides we need a system
that makes more sense and we need
Studios that can stand by their movies
not their ratings because if someone is
honestly gonna tell me a parent should
be present when watching mr. Magoo
I think everybody's trust needs to be
brought into focus
because that should obviously be an
nc-17 that shouldn't be shown anywhere
I'm not Nostalgia Critic I remember so
you don't have to
[Music]
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out this week we are dealing the
Children's Defense Fund they leave no
child behind mission is to ensure every
child a healthy fair safe and moral
start in life and successful passage to
adulthood with the help of caring
families and communities they provide a
strong effective and independent voice
for all the children of America who
cannot vote lobby or speak for
themselves they pay particular attention
to the needs of poor children children
of color and those with disabilities
they educate the nation about the needs
of children and encourage preventive
investments before they get sick drop
out of school get into trouble or suffer
family breakdowns they began in 1973 as
a private nonprofit organization
supported by individual donations
corporate and government grants with a
solid Aon charity watch in several
videos on their YouTube channel to show
the good they're doing you too can help
make sure as many children as possible
deserve the help they need check out the
link and see all the great things
they're doing yourself
[Music]